it's another week and that means it's
time for new releases it's kind of a
slow week so hopefully you took
advantage of some of those great summer
sales but if not here's some games you
can pick up this week there seems to be
no shortage of JRPGs these days but I am
setsuna looks like it could be worth
your time inspired by chrono trigger I
am since una pays homage to some of the
greatest G RPGs of the past and features
a gorgeous art style you've probably
already guessed it but you play assets
una a girl who is supposed to sacrifice
yourself to a fiend in order to restore
the peace you can explore the moody
world of I am Satsuma on the 19th for
PlayStation 4 in PC you've probably
already heard of Ark survival evolved
but have you heard of Ark survival of
the fittest it's basically the same idea
but killing other players is more
encouraged the developer studio wild
card is calling it a multiplayer online
survival arena or mosa for short your
tribe can craft bows spears guns and
bombs all while riding on the back of
giant dinosaurs we are tribe be the last
one standing find out on the 19th for
PlayStation 4 I hope you're ready to die
a lot because it sounds like that's
exactly what you'll be doing in 10
second inja x in this game you play as a
ninja and you have 10 seconds to
complete each mission the game will have
100 levels so 100 times 10 that's about
a thousand seconds which works out to be
16 minutes but that's if you don't die
and it sounds like you will probably die
a lot become a ninja on the 19th for
playstation 4 playstation vita pc and
xbox one if you're a PlayStation Plus
member you should already have access to
this one but if not you can pick up kill
strain this week for free kill strain is
a top-down twin sticks multiplayer
shooter each match is comprised of three
teams two teams of four mercenaries and
one team of two mutants populate the
battlefield the twist is that mutants
can infect mercenaries dramatically
affecting team sizes it sounds like a
cool idea and you can give it a shot on
the 19th this one's already been out on
pc and xbox one but starting this week
playstation 4 owners can get their hands
on lifeless planet lifeless planet is a
puzzle adventure game about an astronaut
seeking life on
distant planet during his expedition on
this foreign planet he comes across an
abandoned Russian town if that hook
doesn't get you I don't know what will
explore the unknown on July 19
PlayStation owners are getting yet
another free to play game this week
called neverwinter if you want to start
playing early however you can get the
Onyx head start pack for twenty dollars
neverwinter is an MMORPG that originally
came out on pc back in 2013 as of now it
sounds like you can't play with pc
players but it sounds like there should
still be plenty for you to do you can
get that on the 19th as well let's end
on a stranger note shall we how about a
game called human fall flat this is an
open-ended physics-based puzzle game
where you try to avoid dreams of falling
you can push stuff you can throw stuff
you can bend stuff and of course you can
break stuff finding new places and
reaching new heights is entirely up to
your imagination you can get this one
for PC on the 22nd let me know at games
you're most looking forward to in the
comments below and remember that these
dates are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they can change until next
time
you